je suis club lorient je suis né à saint
philippe le 11 avril 34 donc 81 ans
cette année si quelqu'un qui a des
convictions qui a une bienveillance à
l'égard des personnes dont il a la
charge et tout particulièrement des
personnes handicapées dont il s'est
occupé avec beaucoup d'attention
c'est quelqu'un qui a marqué son but de
son empreinte l'histoire réunionnaise en
ce qui concerne donc la prise en charge
des personnes handicapées en essayant
pour chaque personne accueillie de faire
en sorte que sa vie devienne une
existence
je suis vice-président de la fondation
père favron est aussi vice président du
gie acheter de grosses associations
occupent maintenant le travail
d'améliorer le sort des handicapés à la
réunion
sa volonté sa détermination de ces parts
étaient à sa propre situation
personnelle est un militant de tout
instant qu'ils le font les ménages qui
sont en lice à peine j'ai eu la peau due
à l'âge de trois ans je suis ravisé donc
des gens et malgré bon c'est son niqab
et là j'ai plus les études avoir un
parcours professionnel très intéressant
beaucoup d'handicapés sens autres parce
qu'ils ont le courage et ils en veulent